some people criticize us for doing what
we're doing like you guys are nuts to
start a business at your age why aren't
you enjoying life well I'm enjoying life
now more than I ever have that's what
some people don't get they see us like
oh God you guys worked so hard what
you're doing now is what you were called
to do you found that at a young age my
role as an insurance broker was not my
calling it's what I did to prepare for
this and I believe there's a lot of
people on the planet that do what they
do as a means to get to this stage of
life and find their true purpose and I
believe everyone has a true purpose
bigger than who they are and they just
have to find it you found it you're
lucky there's no need for you to stop
you get so much joy out of it this isn't
work this is look at us we're having fun
with I'm telling it and I feel the same
way and so does Jody this is so much
more fun than my
career all right here with Markham part
of our uh Mastermind program and as part
of that we do a one-on one together here
in Toronto so great to see you man
looking at your story I mean you've
grown from 0 to 20,000 subscribers yep
in a pretty short amount of time faster
than me well I look because I learned
from your it's been what two years for
you two years May of 20 I think it took
me six years I have to look six or seven
years to get the 20,000 subscribers all
talking now your your channel standed
around retirement yeah it's um
everything non-financial so our our five
pillars that we talk about physical
wellness mental Wellness relationships
spouse partner relationship and then
wisdom sharing what can we do um in this
phase of life to to give back to Mentor
write a book create a YouTube channel do
something to use all of our knowledge
and experience that we've accumulated to
help others where are you thinking in
terms of the next level of your business
that I might be able to help with if
it's the YouTube channel if it's the
business side probably both we you know
Jody and I uh I was an entrepreneur
started and sold several businesses and
the biggest one was an insurance agency
where I was a fourth generation family
business owner with my brother Chuck and
we sold that gosh 10 years ago already
and I stayed on for five years uh
working for the public company and I
just kind of got tired of that so left
and jod worked in Corporate America and
she had a senior level but position in
uh Fortune 200 company and we tried
traditional retirement for a year and we
really got in trouble I mean we traveled
the world and we had a great time and
ate a lot and drank too much gained
weight got tired of the hangovers every
day and realized we were in
trouble and had to Pivot because really
uh for for us part of our inspiration is
my dad who retired at 65 and he was dead
at 80 I mean that's the short story but
basically drank himself to death he was
the the daong Draper of the insurance
industry I call him and he had a bar in
his office and all of that and uh he
didn't invent the three Martini lunch
but he perfected it and the thing is he
took that into retirement which was sad
so we didn't want that same kind of
retirement so we started to to do this
and then I saw you on stage at a at a
meeting and started a YouTube channel a
couple years ago as a let's try this and
see if that helps get the message out
well it did and we're amazed at how well
that we did and now we really want to
take it where we can influence millions
and millions of more people 20,000
subscribers is great and the every time
we get a new subscriber they like oh my
gosh I can't believe I found your
channel this is amazing so we don't do
anything Financial but if you Google um
retirement planning 99.9% of the of what
you get is financial so this this thing
that we're doing we realize uh is
helpful it's actually saving people's
lives had my dad seen our videos I think
he'd still be alive today it's sad that
he
died but he lives on through what Jody
and I are trying to do and I I Googled a
little bit this morning like how many
YouTubers are there and how many
channels and there's if you you probably
know the numbers better than I do but
there's 2.1 Billion YouTube users in the
world
I think there's a billion of them age 35
and older around the world all of these
people don't really want to start a
YouTube channel don't really want to be
a a coach don't want to be a doctor they
all think about retirement because at 35
you're funding your retirement right
401K maybe a pension whatever it might
be but they're not thinking much about
what they're going to do in retirement
they just want to stop working but this
phase of life is complicated and it's
fraught with you know big issues that we
all have when we leave our careers
because during our career we had
fulfillment we had an identity we had a
huge Community our days were filled and
boom that goes away and you're like who
am I now who am I going to hang out with
because those people go away what am I
going to do all day and a lot of people
just wander through this phase of life
and die prematurely
so how do you help us get in front of
these billion people I mean these people
need our help not all of them some
people have it right but you know how do
we grow our Channel how do we become uh
better like we have Facebook and
Instagram and YouTube I you know I'm an
insurance broker I was really good at
that this Jody and I are learning as we
go you guys are in retirement you and
Jody yeah so how much do you want to
turn this into a career Now versus
retirement like how does it fit into
retirement for you it's a great question
because it makes me think that your
perception of retirement might be you
just kind of sit back take it easy and
enjoy the fruits of your
labor but but that's that doesn't work
that's not enough for people um you're
still very young I don't know if you're
thinking about retirement all um but at
some point um you're going to want to
maybe stop doing this I don't don't know
but I think people people are living
longer 50% of babies born today are
going to live to be 100 they're not
going to work till 60 and then stop
that's 40 years or longer Jody and I
have 30 years left so to answer your
question I don't know um we're spending
20 hours a week on this sometimes 30 Jo
Jody and I have this balance where 80%
of my time is on the business and 20% is
with the family Jody's 80% with the
family and 20% on the business and in
that family part we still play golf we
do pickle ball we're meeting friends we
have a huge community so I would say
overall it's 60% of our time is this
which is giving back and helping others
and 40% is not doing nothing but filling
our day with fun stuff yeah I mean I
guess it's one of those things now that
everybody has to Define what retirement
means for them yeah uh I think there's
definitely a preconception of what the
word means that is evolving and shifting
and what it looked like for my parents
is not going to be me right dude I'm
going to do this I'm going to be on a
hospital bed at 120 still hosting
masterminds and doing videos and it's
like I I'm never you know if that's
retirement then I'm already in
retirement you know like I'm already
doing uh what I want to do and I'll do
it forever well you're lucky though see
you're lucky because what you're doing
now is what you were called to do you
found that at a young age my role as
insurance broker was not my calling it's
what I did to prepare for this and I
believe there's a lot of people on the
planet that do what they do as a means
to get to this stage of life and find
their true purpose and I believe
everyone has a true purpose bigger than
who they are and they just have to find
it you found it you're lucky there's no
need for you to stop you get so much joy
out of it it's not work right yeah this
isn't work this is work look at us we're
having fun with we hang out I'm I'm
telling you and I feel the same way and
so does Jody this is so much more fun
than my career yeah so why I asked that
is like you know in in terms of trying
to help I don't want to overload or give
you something that then doesn't fit into
your version of balance and happiness
and retirement uh so thank you the thing
that's going through my head now too is
I wonder if that you don't talk about
finances no but this whole thing that
you and Jody have figured out now with
starting I don't know if you would I
don't know what you call this Enterprise
that you're doing now if it's your own
business if it's whatever you're going
to call it but I think that is that
could definitely be a
pillar in the content as well in showing
people how to
start the next chapter as part of your
channel yeah yeah no we talk a lot about
we call it wisdom sharing so that
component of people's lives but you're
doing more than wisdom sharing okay like
you're starting a business yes whether
you call yourself an entrepreneur or you
have your own business again or however
you want to like The Branding might even
be something that you can
own as okay we're starting our next
chapter which doesn't it doesn't mean
just sit on a golf course and right
three Martini Rule and everything else
but like you could start your own like
people I've helped a lot of people who
are coming out of retirement or who are
going into retirement who are afraid to
start a business okay and have no idea
how to do it and starting over because
they just were told what to do for the
past 40 years and now they have to think
on their own and have their own be
responsible for finding clients and all
the stuff that they have no idea how to
do so wisdom is a piece of it that's the
mission so I think what I'm hearing then
as a component of what we do could be
just really direct about hey one of the
things you can do in this phase of life
is start a
business and I have a friend very good
friend of mine who I'm mentoring now and
he's been for four
years uh he's 72 for four years he's
been looking for a job in his old
industry
advertising and he's struggling with it
he can't find but he wants a job he
wants something to do and all of that
and all of a sudden and I said to him
just keep writing down what you're good
at what you're what you think you want
want to do this opportunity landed in
his lap it's a local um one of these
local community magazines you know live
here now and it's all about the the town
and you get advertisements you get
editorial comments he's going to start
that in his area because one doesn't
exist and it's perfect for him perfect
for him but he never thought that would
be something he could do yeah he wanted
to work for somebody and starting your
own business to go after you know
Fortune 500 companies is hard
but there are businesses people can
start someone just open a retail store
that is you know now I'm thinking about
all the people I know that are doing
this um for Stray Cats um what's the
word adopt the cat I don't know but so
yeah it's she doesn't need to start the
business but that's her passion so yeah
I guess it's interesting to think of
that as a component of what we do well
how much has this project contributed to
your happiness as this next chapter in
terms of your own well besides the
happiness I get from living with jod
it's contributed a lot so living with
her but now you're working together
working together which is interesting
and yeah I'm coaching this guy too
starting this magazine maybe you want to
bring your wife in and he said I thought
about that but then I don't really know
we could coach on that because it's
complicated but it's great I think it's
worth at least considering as a pillar
your five pillars it's your sixth pillar
or whatever but or just alter what
sharing wisdom looks like to because yes
you're sharing wisdom but
there's there's a lot of ways to do it
yeah and one of the biggest things that
people struggle with is starting a new
business feel like they can even what
you're doing starting a YouTube channel
you're going to start a YouTube channel
in your 60s are you crazy what are you
cra like but most people would think
that way people come in retirement no
that's just for the kids like I'm I'm
not going to get on front of a camera
meanwhile like you have the greatest
wisdom to share there's lots of these
videos that go viral of talking to a
90-year-old about life advice yeah
there's a lot of wisdom but people just
feel like they can't they don't know how
to do it all the I don't know I don't
know technology I didn't grow up with
this stuff but all of those things that
you had to overcome and create and now
you've got a successful YouTube channel
teaching other people how they can start
a business as well in their 60s uh 70s
Etc I love that idea it's interesting
you know I I think everyone has a book
in them for sure I'm just finished my
book so I'm excited for that to come out
before the end of the year um everyone
can write a book I don't know if they
should write a book but they all have
stories in their lives to tell and even
if they spend a year doing that write
letters to your kids to your grandkids I
know a woman who's written a letter to
her grandchildren every day for a year
and she's going to put that in the book
and then give it to them under of a
certain age just wisdom but but again a
different pillar Yeah a different pillar
because most people write a book there's
two reasons to write a book either you
just want to put your story out and
share your wisdom or you actually want
to turn it into something and build the
business around it us the most people
who write a book are not then becoming
speakers and and building a coaching
business and everything else on top of
their book it's like I've got these I
wrote you know letters to my
granddaughter every week or that's not a
business it's not a but it's still a
very valid Pursuit and a noble goal and
a a ton of work to put in to create the
book cool that's wisdom sharing but it's
not once you're done after the year
writing the book what do you do do you
write another book you do some other
kind of wisdom sharing uh because you
could then start a business I like
you're pushing me on this because um as
we're talking I'm thinking about it a
little bit uh I'd certainly need to talk
to jod about it but yeah I mean some
people some people criticize us for
doing what we're doing like you guys are
nuts to start a business at your age why
aren't you enjoying life
well I'm enjoying life now more than I
ever have that's what some people don't
get they see us like oh God you guys
work so hard it's not work it isn't but
yes so starting the right kind of
business Having the courage and the idea
and give them some um some some ways in
which to figure out what that might be
is a great idea if you had as a pillar
yes there's a lot of ways to break up
that content it could be you sharing you
and Jody got on here are the 10 ways to
start a business in your 60s or in
retirement right it could be like a
how-to video it could be a documentation
video where you're sharing your journey
and what you're currently working on and
how you're trying to grow your business
it could be a coaching video where you
have entrepreneurs or or recent retirees
come on who are struggling to start
their business you know maybe your
friend yeah and and then you coach them
right but it's all under the pillar of
we're starting a business starting a
business as opposed to just heal and
some of the
yeah I like that it's good idea uh so
anyway we took a little tangent there
but it was fun that was good it was fun
how important for what you're doing now
is the revenue growth of this
project well it hasn't been which is and
is that okay well yes and no uh yes
because we started this as as a hobby
and a passion and we've funded it
ourselves and that's fine um we're
blessed that we can do that but now it's
getting to the point where really to
take it to the next level our expenses
really need to go up if we're going to
do more video which we've talked about
that's an added expense you know the way
we're doing it right now we could just
keep going and and that's what I said to
you you know we go from 20 subscribers
to 20,000 to 30 to 40 we've decided
after reading that great book that U
Benjamin Hardy and Dan Sullivan put out
10x is easier than 2x we want 1 million
subscribers in 5 years so that'll take
more resources so now we need to think a
little bit more about how can we create
products and things like that that
people can buy to help fund this next
level uh for our YouTube channel okay so
there's a couple things to think about
the first is the the content Cadence the
schedule coming out because you guys are
doing a video a week a video a week plus
the short which plus the short so we
could do short every day but yeah and
that helps a little bit honestly if the
goal was only
subscribers like plant the flag this is
the only thing that matters shorts is
going to be your fastest way to get
there okay they won't convert to
anything right and they won't you won't
be impacting really and if they even
subscribe they probably won't watch your
long form content they're not going to
buy any of your stuff for the most part
so a lot of channels have built up to a
million subscribers but but they're
making no money off of their Channel
they so the goal is I just want a
million subscribers care no no we want
to change people's lives okay so so
shorts are fine but this is why again I
asked you
how uh you know the the terms of
workload or workload right because if we
have to go from one video a week to
three videos a week how does that fit
into your life is that doable does that
feel now life is out of balance we can't
do it it depends and when I say it
depends you know our first video two and
a half years ago it took a half a day to
write the script it was word for word
and we had to get it right and then we
it took us a half another half a day to
film a 10-minute video now we do a
script and it's one page it's bullets
and you know we create the content
pretty easy now we film it there's
there's no edits you saw the one where I
fell down and just kept going SC if jod
and I can do a long form video where
we're actually just having a
conversation and we've talked about this
about a topic like even starting a
business we could put together 10 points
that are important to us we don't need
anything else other than well let's talk
about how we decided what business was
right for us and we would just talk
about it y that'd be easy that's we
every morning we have coffee for half an
hour and we chat about stuff chat about
the kids chat about the business chat
about golf game now that might not all
be interesting to our followers but we
could a lot of times it is pretty
interesting and it's pretty deep and
some things that we don't agree on some
things we struggle with those new videos
would be a lot easier for us than the
ones we have now that we want to make
sure we're delivering good valuable
content that's specific and has a call
to action these are
more um you know make them believe we're
having a dinner together and we're
talking about a topic so short answer is
I think we could do that yeah if you
said you need to do three more videos
like you're doing now that's a lot of
work so no definitely not do three more
like you're doing now I would also
challenge the way that you're doing it
now okay and see if that could be done
now it's already gotten faster compared
to two years ago I'm sure my first video
took me a long time to make and it's
it's just a normal issue yeah I think if
you can get to the point where a video
is if it's a set video powerful opinion
right and then bullet form of what
you're going to talk about and then lead
with a powerful opinion like and that
that's what we do now I mean it's one
one page on the teleprompter so it's yes
so it's it it is easier now we can put a
script together in 20 minutes okay like
5 minutes five minutes we'll get it to
five like powerful opinion and then what
like what do you believe about starting
a business in your 60s that most people
don't believe number one that it can be
done number two that there's things they
could do that people would find valuable
number three it's it's not as hard as
you think I mean you clearly couldn't
start a business with the idea that
you're going to hire a 100 employees
it's got to be something that you could
do with one or two other people or by
yourself the main thing people need to
think about if they're starting a
business at this age is what is the one
thing or the two things or the three
things that I know that I need to teach
other people mistakes so the only thing
you're
missing is the skill set to to turn that
into
something repeatable with powerful
opinion and then knowledge so I asked
you what do you believe about somebody
at 67 starting a business that other
people don't believe and you said uh
that it can be done right so you said
like two things that it can be done you
say something else it's not as hard as
you think it's not as hard as you think
yeah so and then you went into
advice okay think about the things that
you can do that can bring value to other
people right and that's where it started
to go go on right the only skill set
difference so I asked you a question and
you got two answers right away like 30
seconds pick one and just lean in on
that answer so it's either uh you you
can do it or was easier than you think
easier than you think yeah like so you
started you started starting the
business at 65 years old is easier than
you
think that's your opening sentence put
that on telepromter like right that down
put on a helicopter what comes after
that you may think that you're too old
and that all these young kids are doing
it but I'm telling you like we've done
it and we did it on a YouTube channel
and it's just it's way easier than you
think and in this video I'm going to
show you how to actually go off and do
it because there's great ideas sitting
inside you right now and like whatever
you're speaking from the heart right but
like one point three
sentences where you gave me three points
and you're you went deep on the how we
all wanted to talk about the how but the
how doesn't matter yet you could talk
forever about the how so three sentences
on the powerful opinion okay so all
that's missing to make these faster is
just that little tweak in the skill set
so powerful opinion give it some context
and the third is tell me what happens to
me if I don't do it so you already know
the model so the stakes memorized yeah
so but then so then just do it right
yeah and then the advice you could like
that's all on a on a I learned that from
a brilliant person by the
way what do you call it the the powerful
content idea you've got perfect thought
leadership template there you go yeah
Power of opinion Contex senses raise a
Stakes but even if you don't like
memorize those three use the use that
structure that structure three sentences
so what do you believe about some about
X that other people don't believe and
then tell me the most important thing
and if you're going to be doing thinking
time over your coffee or whatever with
Jody what is the most important thing
that people don't believe about this
thing that we're about to talk about and
maybe it's that that you can do it or
that it's easier than you think or that
whatever like what is the one most
important thing and just sit on that one
thing for three sentences and nail that
but that as you as you do that more
often it won't take you I mean you still
did it here pretty quickly and the more
you do it the faster it's going to get
for future videos too plus honestly I
have such AE advantage over solopreneurs
because I have a partner and jod sits
next to me and stuff comes to her head
and it comes out and we just flow so
well together and you know we bounce off
of each other and uh we have different
ideas on what we're going to say but
it's it's so creative so it really is
helpful I like I only have to do 50% of
the work she does the other half great
which is so easy me we're here making a
video it's kind of meta right right
we're sitting down for 20 minutes and
this will be a 20-minute video right
there no prep no you know and if I had
to do it alone and just sit here for 20
minutes to be like okay what I what do I
want to say so yeah but you still could
like if you had to you could make a
20-minute video from five minutes prep
powerful opinion Story three bits of
advice so even before going to the
advice story tell me the story about the
72-year-old guy who was trying to get a
job or whatever and then found this
other thing landed in his lap yeah a
good story tell that story that's a good
story but and you've got tons of stories
sure your story Jody's story your dad
story a friend story like depending on
what the the opinion is you tell a
different story the story of the guy
that I saw uh two days ago sitting out
in front of the local Jin Mill 76 year
old guy very successful has a huge
business but every day no it was 3:00
every day he goes to the bar at 3:00 in
the afternoon to drink and I'm not this
isn't anti-drinking it's just that I
said to him what are you up to tomorrow
well I don't know you know if I uh I'm
thinking of going to Florida for a long
weekend I really would love to go for
the whole winter but I can't because I
have this company and if I sell it I
don't know what I'm going to do so he
keeps the company yet he just isn't
living life fulfilling he's just not
taking care of himself and it's sad for
me to see that cuz he's a brilliant guy
he's smart he has family but he's
wasting away his life I'm not judging
him but the fact of the matter is if he
could turn his life around a little bit
and maybe do something different sell
his company have all these Financial
Resources to do some good in the world
that he'd feel
better so on the teleprompter that's
just 76-year-old man outside I know
because you could talk to it you could
talk to and and the most important thing
is that you tap into how you're feeling
about him when you're on camera as
opposed to reading off a script of what
you said let me ask you a question one
of the things and and Jody's the
researcher of the couple so how
important are facts figures
statistics um surveys that were done to
support things that we say all depends
on what you want your brand to be okay
some people lean heavily into that like
if I look in thought leadership Mel
Robbins does that a lot right Mel loves
the latest study and the latest research
it's like according to Harvard y y y y
she has a team of people that throw that
stuff at is great she loves that she
loves data knowing the studies and then
putting a her spin on it to get it to
the map Jody likes that so she could be
that person that brings that but it's
not important because lots of people
when when do I say
statistics I I barely remember you know
my address let
alone right like to look at my phone
number I have to go to my phone and like
see what the phone my own phone number
is right so but I hear that I've read
that you need to appeal to both
audiences some people like statistics
some people don't they like just the so
sure but like there's tons of people who
want to hear the message and the the
last thing you want to do is force
yourself to be a statistics guy and that
then attracts a stats audience when you
don't actually want to be a stats guy
that's good yeah I like that
so you shouldn't do it yeah because you
don't care enough about the stats I get
stuck in it too it's not worth it you
memorize if it's 78 or 72 and like it's
just yeah but if jod loves it and that's
part of her thing cool she can bring it
up but it's not required at all for you
to build a successful Channel that's
good to know yeah so these longer form
videos could be um really either around
the same topics or something like
starting a business you know we could do
three on those and three on something
else it still fits into your pillars
yeah and I think having the freedom to
explore new content formats yeah so it's
not always the same thing I think it's
worthwhile doing and expect it to suck
at the beginning m M and it to be slow
and and maybe awkward and it won't get
results but was it fun because if it's
fun you can you can tweak and improve
and get better right like you don't I
think we're better that way off the cuff
natural authentic because we mess around
with each other a little bit when we we
had the 10minute video structure we're
in a box and sometimes she's kicking me
going like you know we we got to you
know we're at 15 minutes now it should
be 10 yeah uh I think we'd have no
problem talking longer and I think we'd
have frankly more fun I think we look
forward to
that's a good sign yeah so you got the
extra pillar yes with the with the
business content and
then attempting to even with your
current format to it's great that you
went from 2our script into 20 minutes
now how to do it from 20 minutes to five
five minutes yeah and then be able to do
more videos in a day that brings tons of
value and and it's fun for you guys to
create as well yeah cool let's go all
right that was awesome thank you thank
you Evan it was fun appreciate it all
right to watch me coach another
Mastermind member oneon-one check the
video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there it's one year now I
left my accounting job right I was
working at the CPA firm and I was on the
clear path to becoming a partner in The
Firm like I felt like I was living
somebody else's life cuz looking at them
sitting behind the desk nobody looked
happy